[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من العربيه لكم كل التحيه هذه نشره
الخامسه ونستهلها بابرز العناوين
في بطاريات البيطريات مشاركه امريكيه
مباشره في الحرب
[موسيقى]
ماكرون يؤكد على اهميه تحقيق اوروبا اكبر
قدر من الاستقلاليات عن امريكا في عده
مجالات
حقيقيه
في ايران
وتهديدات للفنانين والممثلين
صنعاء
وتمنعهن من العمل والسفر والدراسه
والبدايه من موسكو حيث اكدت رئاسه روسيه
ان تسليمه واشنطن بطاريات بيترياتلي
اوكرانيا لن يمنع روسيا من تحقيق اهدافها
وقال المتحدث باسم الكريم
مباشره على روسيا في اوكرانيا
وتعملوا مع دول الغربيه على اداء اطاله
امد الحرب وعرقله تصلي الى تسويه
بالتزامني وصف نائب رئيس مجلس الاتحاد
الروسي
عفوا
كوستر
الولايات المتحده بتسليم البطاريات
بيتريوس لاوكرانيا بالتدخل المباشر في
النزاع
[تصفيق]
كان يحتاج الى ممثل له في الكونجرس لتمرير
خطته العسكريه واقناع عن اعضائه بالموافقه
على فاتوره الدعم لاوكرانيا ولذلك استدعى
زلينسكي للقيام بهذه المهمه
واضاف نائب رئيس مجلس الاتحاد الروسي ان
ايضا مصمم على زوج الولايات المتحده في
الحرب بحسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
وكان رئيس الاوكراني فولودو ميرسيلين سكي
القى كلمه امام الكونجرس اكد فيها ان
المساعده التي تقدمها الولايات المتحده
لبلاده للتصدي للغزو الروسي ليست صدقه بل
هي استثمار في الامن العالمي واكد زنسكي
ان القوات الاوكرانيه صامده في مواقعها
ولن تستسلم ابدا قبل ان يقدم للكونغرس
علما اوكرانيا جلبه معه من ارض المعركه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قبل ذلك اعلن رئيس الاوكراني خلال مؤتمر
صحفي مشترك مع رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في
البيت الابيض ان حصول اكياف على انظمه
بيتريات للدفاع الجوي سيعزز بقوه قدراتها
دفاعيه مؤكدا ان الامر يشكل خطوه مهمه
للغايه لخلق مجال جويا امنا لاوكرانيا
قائلا لن تكونوا ابدا لوحدكم مشيرا الى
انه وافق واثقا من ان التحالف الغربي سيظل
موحدا وراء اوكرانيا
دكتور
هذه الحرب الفظيعه والولايات المتحده
ملتزمه بضمان استمرار الشعب الاوكراني
شجاع في الدفاع عن بلاده ضد العدوان
الروسي طالما استغرق الامر ذلك
رئيس السلام والعدل
وحريته وسلامته الاقليميه
معي بالموسكو المحلل السياسي الروسي دكتور
رولاند بيجاموف اهلا بك دكتور لماذا
استفزت خطوه اعطاء
البيطريت نظام البيترييت لاوكرانيا روسيا
للمشاهدين لا يوجد هناك سلاح المعجزه في
الحروب
والنظام الدفاع الجوي من الانظمه المعروفه
وحتى وصول بطاريه واحده
يغير شيئا في
في
الميدان قد يكون هناك تعزيز الدفاع الجوي
فيما يتعلق مثلا مدينه معينه على سبيل
المثال همم
العاصمه
ولكن ليه همم خلق نظام الدفاع الجوي همم
فوقه اوكرانيا كلها يجب هناك بطريقه جديده
ومختلفه
ومن المعروف مثلا
مواصفات ولكن لا هو ايضا الضوء فيما يتعلق
قدره همم قدرته على مواجهه صواريخ وجنبها
وطيرات
منظومه مهمه جدا ليست الدوم التي تحظى بها
اسرائيل ولكن منظومه مهمه لماذا بامكان
روسيا ان تلتقي بيلاروسيا ويتحدث بوتن عن
النظام النووي عن تحديث اسلحته النوويه
ولا يجوز الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تقدم نظام بيتريت لاوكرانيا وفي تصريحات
من الموسكم منزعجه من هذا الموضوع
سؤال
اعود ان اريت عليهما من مختلف اولا بنسبه
التهديد النووي من قبل روسيا وهو ليس
تحديد بل امكانيه التعديل العقيده
العسكريه الروسيه بحيث تتطابق مع العقيده
العسكريه الامريكيه فيما يتعلق الاستخدام
السلاح النووي العقيده العسكريه الامريكيه
الاخيره ان 17 اكتوبر من الاعمال الماضي
همم
امكانيه قيامه لبلاد المتحده
بتوجيه ضربه
نوويه العقيده العسكريه الروسيه حتى الان
تقول ان امكانيه همم القيام بالضربه
الجنوبيه اذن هناك الاختلاف في العقيد قال
ربما قد نفكر في تغيير العقيده فيما يتلقى
وروسيا هناك الحديث كثير حول بعروسه هناك
ال- اا قوات الاقليميه الروسيه البيوروسيه
كما تعرفونه هناك دوله اتحاد بين روسيا
وبيلاروس منذ تسعينيات من القرن الماضي
منذ 1997 فلذلك هناك همم
تتواجد والقوات الروسيه حوالي ثمانيه الاف
والجيش البيروسي كله حوالي تعداده الستين
الفرد وضابط
وكل الحديث عن امكانيات القيامه روسيا
بتوجيه ضربه او تكرار الضربه التي كانت في
فبراير في اتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه ليست
لها اي اساس ربما هناك احتماليه موجوده لا
يمكنها استبعادها تماما ولكن هذه
الاحتماليه قليله جدا وتاتي في مجرى
السياسه الاوكرانيه لاستجداع همم وطلب
مزيد من المصاعدات
دكتور
اقول لكم يعني ما يزيد من الاسلحه ودعم
الاوكراني هذا اطاله امد الحرب
هذا
الجانب الروسي
بالحرب
سنسميها كما هي هي حرب بالوكاله بين الغرب
وروسيا هل دخلنا معادله جديده في الحرب
الان بما انه روسي اعتبره انه امريكا دخلت
بشكل مباشر هل 2023 ستبدا بمعارك اكبر همم
باحتلال مباشر بين روسيا والغرب
باختصار شديد اقول لكم الحرب ستستمر لان
لا توجد اي مقدمات تطويل
تخرج عن اطار جغرافي لاوكرانيا نفسها ولكن
اختدام المعارك واا سيكون مزيد من
المصادات العسكريه لاوكرانيا وايضا مثلا
نظام باتريوت
يطلب وجودي طاقم من الخبراء العسكرين
الامريكيين
لاداره وتوجيه همم هذه الانظمه الانفال
يعني الجيش الاخراني غير مجهز لذلك وفي كل
حال من الاحوال سيكون هناك المستشارين
الامريكي ولكن
تواجد المستشارين الحربيين في
ميدان هذا في حاله الذاته همم
الخطوط الحمراء التي دائما
شكرا لك من موسكو المحلل السياسي الروسي
الدكتور رولاند بي جاموس
ان على اوروبا تحقيقه قدر اكبر من
الاستقلاليه عن الولايات المتحده بما في
ذلك داخل الناتو في مجال الامن واضاف
مكحوم في تصريحات او ردتها صحيفه مصر
الجمل انه يجب ان تدافع اوروبا عن نفسها
مشيرا الى ان اوروبا يجب ان تحصل على
استقلاليه تكنولوجيه عن الولايات المتحده
كذلك ان تكون مستقل عسكريا وان تخلق دعامه
اوروبيه حقيقيه في اليوتيوب وقال ماكرون
لا ارى في ذلك مشروعا بديلا عن الحلف
معي من باريس ميشيل ابو نجم الكاتب
السياسي ميشال اهلا بك سيد ميشال هناك
تغيير بلهجه ماكروم اعطى مقابله
لالسائيهل
يتحدث فيها عن نوعا ما من التميز في
السياسه الخارجيه عن السياسه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اقله بموضوع روسيا هل
سنشهد منحه جديد او نوع من النائب النفس
بسبب تبعات الحرب الروسيه على اوروبا
نعم لا اعتقد انه علينا ان نسير في هذا
الاتجاه ولكن الملاحظه جيده بمعنى ان
فرنسا كانت دوما كانت لها رؤى نوعا ما لا
اقول متميزه ولكن لها موسيقاها الخاص
الخاص بالنسبه للعلاقتها مع الحلف الاطلسي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه نذكر هنا
وهذا هذه ذكرى تاريخيه ان بدايه الحلف
الاطلسي كان مقره باريس وان الجنرالدو جول
هو الذي طلب ان ينقل من باريس
الى المقر الى بروكسل كذلك كانت فرنسا جزء
من القياده العسكريه الاطلسيه الموحده
الجنرال دو جول ايضا هو الذي خرج من هذه
القياده لتكون لفرنسا حريات الحركه ولكن
في اطار الغار في اطار الحلف الاطلس يعني
دي ملاحظه الاولى
الملاحظه الثانيه
بالنسبه لموضوع الدعوه دعوه ماكرون
للاستقلاليه الاستراتيجيه لاوروبا لصناعه
دفاعيه اوروبيه لعدم الاعتماد على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بكافه الاشكال
هذا ليس جديد في الواقع انا اذكر هنا بان
اول كلمه اساسيه حول هذا الموضوع للرئيس
مكروه القاها في جامعه السوربون في شهر
سبتمبر 2017 اي في بدايه ولايته الرئاسيه
الاولى منذ ذلك الوقت ما زال رئيس مكرونه
يقول انه يتعين على اوروبا ان تتمكن من
استراتيجيه الا تكون تابعه للولايات
المتحده السياسيه
للدعم السياسي من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي بحاجه للغاز الروسي هي بحاجه
صحيح همم هل يعني هذا قابل للتنفيذ
صحيح لنبقى داخل الحفله الاطلسي لانه اذا
وزعنا الاطار لن يكون هناك الوقت الكافي
لمعالجه كافه
بالطبع اشاره لكم بان واقول من جانبي ان
الوصف الذي الذي يمكن ان يكون صحيحا ان
يصح بالنسبه لاوروبا هي انها مارد اقتصادي
ولكنه قزم من الناحيه السياسيه ومن
الناحيه العسكريه هذا في لنقل في الحمض
النووي ل الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي لم يوجد
اصلا لان يكون قوه عسكريه او قوه سياسيه
فعلا انه تطور مع الوقت المشكله مع طرح
مكروه ان الدول التي كانت خرجت من حلف
وارثته بعد سقوته وخصوصا دول بحر البلطيق
اضافه الى بولندا دول شارك اوروبا رومانيا
وغر ذلك لا تريد لا تريد ان تقايد بين
مظله امريكيه اطلسيه موجوده وفاعله وبين
مظله اوروبيه غير موجوده وغير فاعله نقطه
الاولى النقطه الثانيه الجميع اليوم يتحدث
عن الحرب النوويه كانت تكتيكيه او غير
تكتيكيه والحال ان الدوله النوويه الوحيده
التي بقيت داخل الحلف الاتحاد الاوروبي
بعد خروج بريطانيا هي فرنسا والعقيده
الفرنسيه النوويه غير واضحه يعني فرنسا
تقول انها تدافع عن مصالحها الحيويه
والاساسيه في اوروبا ولكن ما هو التعريف
لا احد يعلم ذلك اذا اليوم السؤال هو هل
هذه الدول ستقبل بما لم تقبله بالامس هذا
غير غير ممكن ابدا لماذا لانه وجدنا لان
الحرب الروسي على اوكرانيا
جاءت بنتيجتين النتيجه الاولى ان وحدت
الحلف الاطلسي بجناحيه الامريكي والغربي
والاوروبي من جهه وفرضت الوصايه الامريكيه
على كل الاطلسي من جهه ثانيه وايضا
بينت ان ان الحرب ممكنه في اوروبا
وان روسيا عادت لتكشر عن انيابها وبالتالي
يتعين على ان تحمي نفسها والحمايه لا يمكن
ان تاتي الا من الدرع الامريكيه لذا فان
دعوه مكروه اليوم تغيرت عن ما كانت عليه
سابقا هو يريد قوه اوروبيه ولكن الى جانب
الحلف الاطلسي وليس
اعتقد ان هذا الطرح يمكن ان يكون مقبولا
اكثر من الاول
ايضا
مصادر تؤكد للعربيه ان ايران تستخدم بنيه
تحتيه سوريه ومواقع سكنيه في دمشق
لاستئناف انشطتها
احييكم من جديد كشفت مصادر للعربيه ان
اسرائيل صعدت من هجماتها على مواقع لحزب
الله اللبناني داخل الاراضي السوريه
واشارت المصادر ان احد الاستهدافات الاحد
الماضي طالت وحده جويه لحزب الله في مطار
القصير السوري الذي تحول لمقر ابحاث
وتطوير المسيرات الايرانيه مصادر العربيه
لفتاه ان الوحده 127 التابعه لحزب الله
التي قصفتها اسرائيل مسؤوله عن انتاج
مسيرات في لبنان وفي يوم الاثنين الماضي
شنت اسرائيل غاره على مقر قياده ايراني في
قلبي دمشق واكدت مصادر العربيه ان ايران
تستخدم البنيه التحتيه السوريه ومواقع
سكنيه في دمشق لاستئنا في انشطتها
قال وزير الخارجيه الايطاليه انطونيو يعني
عندما يحدث في ايران فاقا كل تصورات
واضافت يعني وفقا وفق ما نقلت وكاله نوفا
الايطاليه انه سيقوم باستدعاء السفير
الايراني الى وزاره الخارجيه عندما يتولى
منصبه في روما معتبرا ان ما يحدث في ايران
غير مقبول وفق تعبيره
اعلن موقع وهرانا المعني بحقوق الانسان في
ايران ان عدد المتظاهرين المحكوم عليهم
بالاعدام او المعتقلين المعرضين لخطر
الحكم عليهم بلغ 58 شخصا وفي التفاصيل تم
الحكم على 11 شخصا اخر بالاعدام بينما
يواجهه 47
تهاما قد تؤدي الى عقوبه الاعدام وبحسب
التقرير فهنالك امراه امراه من بين
المتهمين المعرضين لخطر الاعدام
ضع خرابه 500 ممثل ومخرج وعامل في مجال
السينما العالميه من بينهم النجمتان كي
تونسلت وماريو كوتيا في رساله لسلطات
الايرانيه دعوا الى الافراج فورا عن
الممثله تراني اليدوستي اليدوستي التي
اعتقلت لدعمها الاحتجاجات في ايران وتقول
رساله المفتوحه عند توقيت اعتقال اليدوستي
البالغه من العمر 38 عاما قبيله عيد
الميلاد كان متعمدا لضمان
زملائها حول العالم وكانت الممثله تراني
نددت باول اعدام في الاحتجاجات الاخيره
بحق المتظاهر محسن شكري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معي من امستردام الصحفي الايراني يعقوب
سعيد اهلا بك سيد يعقوب هل هو استراتيجيه
جديده لنظام الايراني بالتصويب على مشاهير
ممثلين اصحاب راي في ايران وما الهدف من
ذلك
طيبه لك والمفضيه قناه العربيه بكل تاكيد
يعني بالتالي هؤلاء الاشخاص ومؤثرين في
المجتمع والنظام الايرانيه تخوف جدا من
تضامنهم مع الاحتجاجات ودفع ويعني التعبير
عن تضامن حتى حتى لو كان ذلك على عبر
السوشيال ميديا او كذلك نزولهم الى
الشوارع هذا يدفع بشرائح واسع من المجتمع
هؤلاء الناس هم لديهم تاثير لديهم كثير من
المتابعين الذين يتاثرون باقوالهم
ولذلك ويتخوف من هذه الاصوات اكثر من
تخوفهم من الاشخاص العاديين الذين يخرجون
الى الشوارع لذلك ويستهدف ترانا مثلا على
سبيل المثال يحاول اعدامها لبث الخوف
الرعب في نفوس المؤثرين الاخرين يعني هو
هنا الهدف الاساسي من اعدام ترانا او
اعدام شخصيات مؤثره ليس الشارع العادل
المتظاهر العادي في الشارع المؤثرين
الاخرين اصحاب المكان بالمجتمع
حتى لا حتى هؤلاء الاشخاص لا يتخذون نفس
الموقف الذي اتخذته ترانا في مسانده
الاحتجاجات
يعني اعدام عدد كبير من الناس 10 12 20 15
مقابل اعدام شخص مشهور او له تاثير في
المجتمع همم هل هذا بميزان ذاك
لا بكل تاكيد يعني نحن راينا ذلك من خلال
نتائج اليوم على الشارع يعني ما زالت
الاحتجاجات مستمره كذلك من الناحيه
النفسيه يعني هؤلاء المتظاهرين كل ما يعدم
شخص كل ما يشعرون بالمسؤوليه تجاه هذا
الشخص وبالتالي هذا يدفعهم للاحتجاج اكثر
وللاستمرار بالتظاهرات ايضا راينا بان
الاعدامات زادت من رقعه الاحتجاجات اعطتها
يعني اوجه اخرى للتعبير يعني تحول سرعته
تحول الجنازات مثلا الى ايضا مسيرات
احتجاجيه ضد هذا النظام الايراني فلا تصور
بان هذه هذه الاعدامات ترجع الناس على
العكس تماما حتى اعدامات ولدت انقسامات
داخل هذا النظام يعني عندما ينظر الى
تصريحات محمد رضا رحمه هو ايضا عضو مكتب
استفتاء الخميني قال بان جميع الاشخاص
الذين اعدمهم لا تتوفر بهم شروط هؤلاء يجب
اما نفهم او قطع يدهم او ارجلهم هذه ايضا
يعني همم مرفوضه ولكن
ال- ما اريد ان اقول او مثلا على سبيل
المثال الشخص الاخر هو مرتضى مقتدي رئيس
السابق المحكمه العليا ايضا قال بان اصل
لا تتوفر بين شروط الحراس واريد ان اقول
لكن بعلم السياسه والاجتماع العنف والقمع
همم يفلح يعني عندما تقتل هذا الكم من
الناس تتمكن من اخافه المجتمع ما هي الطرق
المتاحه امام المجتمع الايراني
ليكمل همم احتجاجه ويعني اهداف التغيير
التي يريدها
اتصور بان اهم طريقه ممكن ان تدفع الناس
الاستمرار هو التضامن مع هذه الاحتجاجات
خاصه التضامن من قبل دول الغربيه
الخطوات التي قام بها الكثير من نواب
الغربيين والقدوه الكفاله السياسيه لاشخاص
الذين يتم الذين متهمين او صدرت احكام
الاعدام بحقهم هذه على المستوى العملي
ممكن ليس لها تاثير ولكن على مستوى نفسي
تعطي امال للمحتاجين بان اصواتهم تسمع على
المستوى العالمي ايضا
محاصره ايران على المستوى الاقتصادي قطع
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع ايران من الناحيه
العالميه هذا يدفع المحتاجين يعطيهم امانه
بان التغيير قادم فكل ما زاد هذا الامل كل
ما زادت رقعه الاحتجاج في ايران
يعقوب سعيد
على خطى طالبان بتضيق الخناق على النساء
وتقييد حركتهن بدات مليشيات الحوثي في
مناطق سيطرتها بعزل الموظفات اليمنيات عن
الرجال في المكاتب في الحله مكاتب
الحكوميه وغرف مستقله عن رجال في المؤسسات
الحكوميه كما تم منع الموظفات من تنفيذ اي
مهمات الميدانيه خارج المكاتب هذا عدا عن
فرض الطالبات في المدارس والجامعات على
ارتداء الجلباب وتغطيه وجوههن بالكامل
وعدم الاختلاط مع الطلبه كما قد منعت من
الحوثي تنقل نساء وسفرهن بين المحافظه
والمدن والى خارج البلاد دون محرم قرارات
الحوثي هذه لقد سقطا واسعا في اوساط
اليمنيين في اشاره الى ان الحوثيين
يستهدفون المراه تهديدا لحرمان او تمهيدا
لحرمانها من التعليم وحقها في مزاوله
العمل والمشاركه في الحياه العامه
بينها وبين الحلم بالدراسه حلم بالعبور
الى البلد المقصود تحاول القبضه الحوثيه
تحطيما عبير المكتري شابه يمنيه من محافظه
تعز ارادت استكمال تحصيلها العلمي في مصر
بعد حصولها على منحه دراسه هناك
لكن مليشيات الحوثي ابتسمح لها بذلك ربما
اليقينها بوهان رصاصها امام قوه رصاص قلم
بين انامل عبير
فلاحقتها وغلقت الابواب امامها فلم يعد
بامكانها المغادره لا جوا عبر مطار صنعاء
ولا برا باتجاه مطار عدن بعد
القاهره
من السفر من قبل الحوثيين في مطار صنعاء
فقلت اسافر بدل ما اسافر من مطار صنعاء
اسافر من مطار عدن
وانا بطريقي لعدم تم نعيم مره ثانيه من
قبل الحوثيين
القصه هي عبير ومثلاتها القصه هي المراه
اليمنيه بل اكبر القصه شعب مورتهن بقبضه
ميليشيا تجبرت بالسلاح فسامحت لمواليها
ومنعت عن الاخرين وما من سبيل سوى الكلمه
عبر الكتابه وفضح هذه الاساليب واستنكارها
او عبر التواصل مع المجتمع الدولي في حاله
انه يستطيع الضغط على هذه المليشيات عبير
مثالها كمثل شابه افغانيه او صدق الطالبان
ابواب الجامعات والمدارس دونها لان امراه
متعلمه ستنشئ جيلا سيرهق بوعيه حاكمه
حوثيا كان ام من طالبان ام اخرين
يمنى جلاس العربيه
معي من القاهره الدكتوره وسام سند والنشطه
اليمنيه في شؤون حقوق الحقوق والحريات
اهلا بك يا دكتوره لماذا يفعل الحوثيون
هكذا بالمجتمع اليمني الغريب عليه هكذا
عادات خاصه يعني في اوساط معينه المراه
يحق لها التعليم والكثير من اليمنيات
مبدعات في المجتمع والعالم
مساء الخير عليكم
هذه الجماعات الارهابيه المتطرفه خلينا
نقول مليشيات الاسلام السياسي
الشيعيه السنيه الزيديه لا تختلف عن بعض
البعض في اخر المطافئ لتكون جميعا في فرض
هذه القيود خاصه على المراه همم سنجد هذه
النموذج لطالبان سنجده في داعش في المناطق
سيطرت عليها ده عيسى سنجده في همم في
الشيطان الاكبر همم
نظام الملالي في طهران كانت هذه البدايات
للاسف الحوثيين يبداون من حيث يعني الان
ال- ال- الايرانيين الايرانيات ينقضون
للمطالبه بحريات اكثر والحوثيون يريدون ان
يعودون الى ما قبل الى بدايات هذه الثوره
همم الثوره للخمانيه في في ايران همم نجد
هذا النموذج واضحا وصارحا اليوم يشهده
العالم كله همم في طالبان لم يعد احد يمنع
النساء من التعليم والطالبات من المدارس
والنساء من الجامعات الا الا هذه النماذج
في طالبان وداعش والقاعده الحوثيون للاسف
يقودون الى الى هذا الى هذا الطريق بخطوات
خلينا نقول متسارعه فقط خطوات بطيئه
اصدروا من من شهر الماضي مدونه السلوك
الحوثيه وكان اليمنيين كان يفتقدون
يفتقدون السلوك ويفتقدون الدين ويفتقدون
الاخلاق ثم جاء الحوثيون يريدون ان
يفرضونها عليهم كانت هذه المدونه وكل
القيود المفروضه على النساء تقود في هذا
السياق وهذا السياق ايضا يعني ان المراه
لم تعمل ولن تتعلم ببساطه شديده لماذا
لانه نحن في ظل همم بلد يعاني ظروف
اقتصاديه صعبه بالاساس في اي شركه واي
مؤسسه هذه التي بامكانها ان تجعل هناك قسم
النساء يعني اعتراضنا على المبدا ولكن حتى
لو سلمنا جدلا اي شركه او مؤسسه ستستطيع
ان تجعل هناك ملحق خاصه همم للنساء بدايه
ثم هناك عزوف ايضا انه سيجعل المجتمع يعني
همم
مؤسسات العمل ابتعد عن النساء بعد المساء
لانه هذا سيكلفها الكثير سيكلفها همم
مباني خاصه للنساء او غرف خاصه النساء
تعمل تحتاج الى ساعات عمل اضافيه
انه سياسه العزل في العالم شاهدناها العزل
صقر الجيش العزل العنصري ومن ثم جاءت هناك
همم سمات اخرى لهذا العزل يعني خرج العالم
من هذه الطريقه الان ربما الحوثيون يعودون
لها انت يمنيه ودكتوره
اخبريني عن تجربتك ان تكوني متعلمه واهميه
ان تكون امراه سواء كانت يمنيه ام لا
متعلمه
والله خليني اقلك بوضوح نحن عندنا الاصوات
لحتى اصوات المتعلمات تنقسم يعني خليني
لازم في هذه المكان لا يمكن ان نخدم الا
ان نذكر ان هناك الكثير من نساء الحوثيات
المتعلمات الغير محجبات يجيبون العالم
يدافعون عن الحوثي ويحولون التزييف حقيقه
الحوثي امام المجتمع الدولي بل يقولون نحن
نحن نموذج من هذه النماذج التي يصدرها
الحوثي ويدافعون عن الحوثي ويظهرون بمظهر
همم يعني
يليق
بالتخاطب مع المجتمع الدولي وينسون هؤلاء
الملايين من النساء في الداخل التي تمارس
تمارس عليهن المليشي الحوتيه هذه الضغوط
وهذه الظلاميه وهذا السواد همم في حياته
يعني ال- ال- ال- ال- ال- المجتمع اليمني
الان يفقد يفتقد الكثير من الرجال بسبب
هذه الحرب التي افقدت الكثير من الاسرع
لها يعني موضوع العمل لم يعد موضوع على
فهي او موضوع اثبات للذات او اثبات وهذا
حق للمراه في كل مكان وفي كل زمان لكن
ايضا حاجه الان في المجتمع كالمجتمع
اليمني الذي اصلا المراه تعول العديد من
الاسر من الاسر في ايضا كيف ستعمل المراه
كيف ستقطيع ان تقود مجتمع وهي همم يعني
غير متعلمه او تمنع من حقها في التعليم
يعني صراحه نحن نتحدث بالف باء الحقوق همم
للنساء للاسف هناك من يتعامل ايضا مع
النساء المتعلمات ايضا يتعاملون برفاهيه
مع قضايا مع قضايا النساء يعني قيمه همم
واجتماعات نسائيه ودعوات للسلام ولكن لا
تقدم شيء لهؤلاء النساء التي يعاني فعلا
حتى الخروج حتى السفر
يخرجنا بدون محرم ومعظم الرجال هناك فقدوا
حياتهم في اليمن كيف حتى تخرج اليمن غير
محرم يعني حتى لو سلمنا جدلا بهذه الشروط
التجهزيه شكرا لك من القاهره دكتوره وسام
بسام دواء الناشطه اليمنيه في شقق في شؤون
حقوق والحريات
ونشره الخامسه مستمره ولكن بعد فصل قصير
احييكم من جديد
الخامسه من بريطانيا تستعد هيئه الخدمات
الخدمات الصحيه الوطنيه البريطانيه
ضغط كبير في مستشفياتها من الان وحتى عيد
الميلاد مع الاضراب القائم في طواقي
المستشفياتها والاسعاف كبار الاطباء في
بريطانيا حذروا من تدهور حاله المرضى
وسرعه الوصول الى العلاج بسبب توقف
الموظفين عن العمل بشكل واسع في تواقم
المستشفيات والاسعاف كما قال رؤساء في
الهيئه ان المستشفيات تواجه تراكم في
العمليات و تاجيل مواعيد العيادات بسبب
الاضراب الحظ الحاصل مع موظفي الاسعاف ومن
المحتمل ان تمتد تداعيات الاضراب في نظام
الصحه والرعايه الى الايام القادمه مع
توقعي اعداد كبيره جدا من مكالمات الطوارئ
معي من لندن الصحفي محمد شبارو اهلا بيك
محمد بريطانيا على موعد مع الكثير من
الاضرابات الممرضات الامبلنس
والقطارات في كافه القطاعات ااا ساتحدث
اولا من جانب الحكومه الى متى تستمر عمليه
الابتزاز هذه يتم شل البلد وتعطيت تعطيل
البلد بالكامل
تبالغ جدا ايضا في ضرب عرض الحائط في
اسرارها على عدم الجلوس الى الهيئات
التوظيف او ان تتوسط بينهم وبين الهيئات
الناظمه لمساله رفع الاسعار انا ما كتبه
وزير الصحه في ال ال الصحيفه قبل يومين
بارك الوزير كان ايضا يعني مستفزا
للنقابات العمال واليوم الحكومه ليست في
وضع تتحمل فيه ابتزاز بعد تخبط السنوات
الماضيه الذي رايته بام العين استاذ ريما
هنا في بريطانيا
وضروره عدم التمسك باديولوجيا مسبقه وربما
التوسط الى حلول
الان لمطالب النقابات لانه يعني نحن نشعر
انه حتى ريشه سوناك لن يصمد بشكل كبير
ببدايه 23 يعني سيسقط ايضا هو ادرس ما
استمر الوضع
النقابات اليوم وطلبها كثيرا نعم نقابات
التمريض تطالب ب 19% زياده
وهي زيادات تاتي بمفعول رجعي لانه هناك 54
سنوات لم تحصل الممرضات والممرضين على اي
همم زياده في المرتبات هناك اديولوجيا
قديمه في حزب المحافظين ربما كانت جيده
بعدم الانصياع
للنقابات في مطلع الثمانينيات عندما كسرت
النمط القديم في الاضرابات اليوم هناك
تعاطف شعبي كبير هناك سوء احوال معيشيه
كبيره تضرب الغني والفقير في شمال البلاد
وفي جنبها ولذلك اعتقد ان على الحكومه ان
تتحلى بنوع من المسؤوليه وان تدخل في جبل
مع النقابات لكي يعني يتمكنوا من حل هذه
المساله بحلول وسط يعني بالمئه زياده ممكن
10% او 7% اريد ان ايضا ايضا المشاهدين
الذي يقصدون لندن انه قد نكون امام الكثير
من الاضرابات تشل هيثرون نوعا ما او تاخر
اجراءات الوصول الى داخل البلاد عبر
الباسبور كنترول جوازات السفر همم حتى
ثاني اسبوع من يناير في اضرابات هل تصمت
حكومه ريشي صنعك
انا اعتقد ان الان ليس هناك بديل وان حزب
المحافظين وحكومه ريشي سوناك ستصر على
البقاء حتى الانتخابات التي بنظرهم ستبدا
مساله التضخم بالانخفاض او الانحسار اذا
صاحب تعبير في الربيع المقبل او الصيف
المقبل وبالتالي ربما
يطالبون باجراء بانتخابات على امل ان يبقى
حزامك
عامين قبل ان يفرض عليه طلب للانتخابات
ولكن بالامكان ان يطلب همم اجراء هذه
الانتخابات قبل ذلك الوقت همم استاذه ريما
هناك ايضا اضرابات قطاع التعليم مقبله
ويعني وقطاعات اخرى لم نسمع بها من قبل
مقبله بعد يناير ايضا هذا ما يتحدث به
يعني كثير في الاوساط البريطاني كثيرون في
الاوساط البريطانيه بان يعني شتاء البؤس
مستمر وان هذه الحكومه
تحدد اولوياتها بشكل مسؤول يسمح لها ربما
باعاده الانتخاب في الانتخابات عامه مقبله
ولكن اعتقد ان الانتخابات اصبحت الضروريه
محمد الشتاء البؤساء في اوروبا وليس فقط
في بريطانيا ولكن بريطانيا الاكثر تضررا
شكرا لك من لندن صحفي محمد شبارو
فلسطين
بمعركه ماساويه مع فيروس كرونه حيث يتوقع
اصابه نصف سكان المدينه البالغ عددهم 25
مليون نسمه بحولولي نهايه العام وفقه
رويترز ويشرح الفيروس الصين دون رابع
اثرها تحولها المفاجئ عن سياسه صفر كوفيت
هذه هي وقفه مع ابرز احداث او احداث مارس
هذا العام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسيل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعلن اليوم
في هذه اللحظه التاريخيه
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وصل رئيسه
الاوكرانيسكي الى بولندا قديما من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفي طريقه الى
اوكرانيا وعقد ذلك مباحثات مع رئيس
البولندي اندريه دودا فوق فورا استقباله
بالمطار
بعد اربعه سنوات من وصوله الى سطح الكوكب
الاحمر اعلنت اداره الطيران والفضاء
الامريكيه ناسا رسميا تقاعد مركبه الفضاء
الموجوده بالمريخ انسايد وهي اول مسبار
الي صمم خصيصا لدراسه الاجزاء الداخليه
العميقه لعالم بعيد
[موسيقى]
اعلنت سلطات والمحليه في البرازيل ان
شخصين لقياحذفهما على الاقل جراء الامطار
الغزيره التي ضربت ولايه سانتا كاترينا
جنوب البلاد
[موسيقى]
الى اللقاء